et bien bonjour comment ça va nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec la casa dépeints
tels la capelle la série où est la
maison de la monnaie et c'était mcfly
géographe you're a rich je vois rien du
tout la philly fait figure de surdoué de
l'adaptation elle atteint des sommets
dans l'art de la 4 face à youtube la
vidéo à 20 secondes bienvenue à tous ces
vidéos sont des genres de catharsis un
exutoire c'est à dire mais faire voilà
bon les a mais on arrête la casse le
pape mais nous sommes réunis ici non pas
pour prier dieu mais pour ouvrir des
balles et certains numéros 1 quasiment
bien ton numéro un a échoué messieurs
non les gars l'égard des gars des amis
je ne suis pas retourné au japon depuis
la dernière fois que tu manges et
maliennes dans ma vidéo de madeleine
saint michel ouais attend il a fait une
super on ne pouvait pas faire mieux dans
cette vidéo vous voyez ce genre de gag
il va y en avoir beaucoup
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous allons des
balles et des objets de farces et
attrapes suis le seul à être
enthousiaste le concept tout simple et
farces et attrapes et moi c'est une
grande histoire d'amour
ceci est la moutarde est ce que tu peux
réussir
[Musique]
non là où tu sais vous regardez bien les
diamond l'automne
regardez bien sa c2 ogier côte à côte
c'est ça c'est ça youtube
vous l'aurez compris dans cette vidéo je
réalise un rêve d'enfant j'ai acheté
beaucoup de farces et attrapes lâche 7
buts j'ai acheté beaucoup de farces et
attrapes et on va les ouvrir ensemble
avec ma famille avec moi je sais les
objets que j'ai pris mais ils ne savent
pas donc je vais refaire découvrir il ya
des objets je vais le ramenez vous en
aurez entendu parler toute votre vie et
enfin vous l'aurez de bon goût 16h une
relation sexuelle avec une femme
consentante
comme dans chaque vidéo on déballe des
objets il ya une tradition qui a été
mise en place et qui s'appelle les
costumes
hu on a fait ça non est ce que vous
saviez que ceux ci existent et la
maturité elle est définie par courtois
les gens nous disaient nous avons vous
avez des enfants ben dis donc on paye
des impôts la maison de campagne
on travaille dur la vaisselle c'est pas
la meuf qui fait c'est tout le monde qui
fait il ya un ensemble pendus du logis
domestiques ménage relations familiales
je me fais chier lahoud à d'ores et déjà
très large donc le costume donner plus
pour moi il ya un matin ah oui demain au
non j'adore façon dès qu'on a une tête
comme ça dans la vidéo c'est j'adore
malata tavini atteint quasiment le faire
une petite pause bord assez long là
[Musique]
imaginer mes enfants plus ton travail
c'est quoi comme mais est ce que vous
venez à ces impies réplique de flûte
jamais vu quoi tout est la plus raide à
séoul s'est classé non quoi non mais
c'est pas ça va je fais également qu'un
petit bijou est certainement beaucoup et
me boulet ce rebond le petit câlin du
second ayant émis un poteau japonais
sont tellement meilleur que les français
en gags ya même pas là qu'on appelle ça
la petite racine bernard si elle est là
[Applaudissements]
peut-être pu avoir l'aide de l'un de
vous deux sens proche de 3 m
aubin moi je regarde ailleurs je regarde
dans cette direction c'est une direction
et parfaites là ça va être l'éclatement
vous allez voir cela c'est l'éclaté vous
rappelez de jackass away allez je me
prépare psychologiquement prêt à délirer
on va péter un plomb on va être hype et
savane ou turner poteau toi david pour
mémoriser cette vidéo oui ça va marcher
c'est censé être un appareil photo qui
envoie de l'eau ça ce qui est important
c'est d'en faire attention aux think you
can dance it clap la deuxième qu'est ce
que c'est ça fait l'électricité horrible
que moi km à l'est les gens n'ont rien
vu c'est vraiment la pire chose dégager
un bail génial petit extrait d'émail
géniaux qui a vu dans cette vidéo déjà
les amis est ce que vous connaissez cet
objet un dentier qui s'agitent tout seul
lorsqu'on pose sur une table on va
s'éclater
ça va aujourd'hui on l'a on devrait
enfin tu en profites et c'est sûrement
le meilleur moment de toute la vie des
noms mais les gars enfin regardez
regardez vous et je voudrais bien les
gains des meilleurs étudiants de france
et on assiste à des séances total bon
les gars ça fait long pour faire un
petit bond qui veulent ouvrir tu peux
second tour parce que c'est à la donne
ils ont mis le doigt de petit calibre et
évidemment c'est même plus c'est vrai
plus c'est beau un truc est ce qu'on
peut emmener de cette séquence pour alan
tissières
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
ça soit pas du poil à gratter par
exemple par hasard qui veut tester le
point jeunes ça se présente comme du
poil
c'est vrai bah ouais
[Musique]
bon les gars qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir
cet objet attention c'est devine tu ne
voulais quand était en cours absolument
cet objet tu sais pas trop ce que les
gens ou s'il existait vraiment le stylo
qui efface ce qui réécrivent nom du
stylo qui écrit tout seul non le stylo
avec des dents les identifier j'allais
dire des parents pas séparé vous n'avez
jamais rêvé la bastide après les
vacances étaient mal les vacances la
rentrée ça se passe j'ai vu lady mignon
la vidéo convient bien aux félicitations
même temps à trouver une direction là
qui déchirent sur youtube des gens et
qui fut un temps les gens qui disaient
tu as vu ce qu'il fait et puis oui c'est
ça c'est dans la lignée tu vois ces
genres les gens ils apprennent des trucs
qui découvre des choses et puis à une
manière ludique qui s'est mis tout ce
qui lui arrive sur cette [ __ ] de
vidéos le coeur du canton mais je peux a
commandé à 6,6 à toi comment tu sais où
tu as regardé dans le carton je l'amène
suis là haut le nom réalisé pas mal ils
m'ont pas je me montrais de l'envers du
décor mais on fait comme si je marchais
sur duke à calais
à odos et ma merde mais du pied gauche
ça porte bonheur
d'un pistolet route
regardes tu fais ça en appuyant sur le
monde au bord dans les cages vous et
mito voici le nouvel objet climax de la
vidéo s'ouvre dans cet objet non j'ai
des vertiges les gars n'ont mangé ce
matin
cool merci poule d caramelo soutif
outils
a besoin d'ouvrir sept vont commencer et
là je vais l'appeler essayer de ne pas
quitter ton c'est ce disque dur rires
les gars je me dis un truc pour de vrai
le prochain objectif
cette fois c'est le rêve de toute une
vie
jean faisait défaut avec mon frère en
alliant de tout mais j'ai pas dire ce
qui est des jeunes qui ont produit un
jeu mon avis qu'ils fassent que ce soit
celle des vrais fumigènes aux eaux
bonnes idées plutôt bonne il alors est
ce qu a votre avis il marche parce que
ça vient du même site que le reste je
voulais un petit peu les héros comme ça
qui a écrit n'est utilisé que dans un
espace bien aéré attention à lui et à
bout de banc à l'aide d'une allumette
alors j'explique un truc mon bureau
c'est l'ancien fumoir du bâtiment donc
là un peu de chance ils ont jamais
réactive et d'éditeurs fumer c'est pour
ça que l'adn fois qu'on a fait développe
puisse tout dans le bureau savait rien
déclenché j'espère si je me trompe
on est mort allez allez allez allez
un seul pour le moment
[Musique]
deuxième chance
pacsé avec toi moi c'est beau alors on
est bien d'accord mais on est comme à la
forêt et j'entends les grilles autour du
vin vas-y je sais où je peux faire un
peu les yeux
[Musique]